ripped to the ground just seconds this
was an historic moment statue to this
17th century slave trader has stood for
more than 120 years he now lies at the
bottom of the city's Harbor 10,000
gathered for the black lives matter
protest in Bristol and while George
Floyd was killed then he 4000 miles away
the impact was felt just as strongly
why would I walk past that every day
knowing the history of it that literally
makes me feel like I don't matter so
that that says black lives matter I
guess I was supposed to like look at it
as if he was some sort of like hero
someone that was worthy of being
immortalized and like I think that's
actually it sent a very very strong
message of white supremacy so I think
it's difficult to to know whether this
is just on something incredible I mean
this is actually being up down death
definitely is I think so much more needs
to be done there is no escaping Edward
Colston in Bristol his name adorns
buildings throughout the city he has
long been a key and controversial figure
more than 11-thousand having already
signed a petition to remove his statue
this is something that should have
happened years ago but the council
failed to act and even before I started
the petition there have been numerous
groups campaigning for the removal of
the statue and rightly so because
Bristol is a multicultural and diverse
City in the end no petition was needed
there's no doubt that this is a very
significant moment for Bristol it is a
city which has slavery ingrained in its
history the big question though is
whether this is the start of something
bigger
a police investigation into those
responsible is now under way the actions
of a small minority here condemned by
the Home Secretary I think that is
utterly disgraceful and that speaks to
the acts of disorder public disorder
that actually have now become a
distraction from the cause in which
people are actually actively protesting
about the question now is what next
statues celebrating Britain's colonial
past stand in cities across the country
there is now one less as the black lives
matter movement continues to build
momentum
dan whited Sky News in Bristol